[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابرز
العناوينز
يضع ثقل حكومته لمزيد من الانهيار ولمنعي
مزيد من انهيار للبنوك بعد سيليكون فالي
واسهم البنوك تربك البورصات
اول لقاء بين الرئيسين الاوكراني والصيني
سيكون عن بعد والكرملين السابق القمه
اهدافنا لن تتحقق الا بالقوه
[موسيقى]
قمه امريكيه بريطانيه استراليه عنوانها
بناء الغواصات النوويه لخلق توازن ببحر
الصين الجنوبي
تجهز العدل الدنيا
الفلسطينيه يعبر عن انزعاج واضح من خلال
البلاغ
من نوعه الديوان الملكي المغربيه ينتقدوا
حزب العداله والتنميه لمزايدته على مواقف
البلاد الخارجيه
ارتباك كبير تسبب به افلاس بنك سيليكون
فالي للاسواق والبورصات الامريكيه
والاوروبيه الاسهم في الاولى
سرعان ما عادت او خبطت سرعنا ما عادت
للارتفاع بعد هبوط متوقع لكن الاسهم
الاوروبيه اغلقت على انخفاض حاد الرئيس
الامريكي تدخل بنفسه لايقاف انهيارات
البورصه واسهم البنوك حيث توعد بمحاسبه
المتسببين بانهيار بنك سيليكون فالي وقال
ان النظام المصرفي الامريكي امن وبامكان
المودعين الوصول لاموالهم دون عوائق
تحرك سريعا لاحتواء تداعيات انهيار بنك
سيليكون فالي بامكان المودعين الوصول الى
اموالهم بدون عوائق المستثمرون الذين
يخاطرون بودائع الامريكيين ستتم محاسبتهم
ولن تكون هناك حمايه لاصحاب قرارات
المخاطر التي ادت لهذه الازمه ولن نسمح
بتكرار اخفاقات البنوك وسنعمل على حمايه
الشركات الناشئه اريد التاكيد على ان
دافعي الضرائب لن يتحملوا اي خسائر بسبب
ازمه البنوك
من جانبه حضر الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
بلغه شديده اللهجه من الانهيار الاخير
لسيليكون فالي حيث القى باللوم على سياسات
الاقتصاديه لبعض مشيرا الى ان هنالك
المزيد من الكوارث الماليه تلوح في الافق
مع ما يحدث للاقتصاد الامريكي من ازمات
والمقترحات المقدمه حول زياده نسبه
الضرائب في البلاد
[موسيقى]
بنك سيليكون فالي مجله نظام التامين
الفيدرالي يغطي ودائع تصل الى 250 الف
دولار ويحمي جميع الاموال النقديه لمعظم
الافراد في حساب المصرفي حجم المدخرات زاد
من 44 مليار دولار نهايه 2017 الى 189
مليار دولار في نهايه 2021
نمو القروض من 23 مليارا الى 66 مليار
دولار وجود ودائع اكبر بكثير من القروض
استثمار 128 مليار دولار نهايه 2021
معظمها في سندات الرهن العقاري وسندات
الخزانه الانهيار له تداعيات عالميه بينها
سوق العملات المشفره وتاثير سلبي على
الشركات التقنيه او الناشئه صحيفه
الجارديان العديد من الشركات والافراد قد
يخسرون اكثر من نصف ودائعهم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ننتقل الى الزميله لارا حبيب
وتطورات الاسواق الامريكيه في التعاملات
الحاليه اليك لارا
شكرا لليال اذا مشاهدينا تطور كبير نراه
في الاسواق الامريكيه بعد ان بدات هذه
الجلسه على تراجعات قويه تعود الان لتسجل
ارتفاع لاحظوا مكاسب الداود جونس ثلاث
اعشار بالمئه والارتفاعات الاكبر هي من
نصيب الناس بواحد. لماذا هذا الاداء
الايجابي للاسواق الامريكيه لانه الاسواق
تراهن الان بانه الفيدرالي ممكن ان يبطئ
من وتيره رفع الفائده في اجتماع الثاني
والعشرين من الشهر الجاري كان في احتماليه
كبيره قبل هذه الازمه بان يقدم الفيدرالي
برفع الفائده ب 50 نقطه اساس الان تتراجع
هذه الاحتماليه الى 25 نقطه اساس والبعض
حتى جود من يتوقع انه الفيدرالي لن يرفع
اسعار الفائده هذا ما يؤدي الى الارتفاعات
في اسواق الاسهم وخاصه على اسهم
التكنولوجيا التي تتاثر تقييماتها اكثر من
غيرها باتجاهات اسعار الفائده ولكن اسعار
البنوك ما زالت عليها ضغط اليوم في
الاسواق الامريكيه هذه السنه التكنولوجيا
قبل البنوك لاحظوا الارتفاعات التي نراها
هناك لننتقل الى القطاع المصرفي اليوم يجب
ان نفرق بين البنوك الكبرى والبنوك الاصغر
في الولايات المتحده البنوك الكبرى عليها
القواعد التنظيميه هي اشد من البنوك
الصغرى لانه بعد الازمه الماليه العالميه
كان في قانون دوت فرانك الذي
ينظم البنوك بشكل عام القطاع المصرفي
ويمنعها ويحد من قدرتها على اتخاذ المخاطر
في العام 2018 في ظل مساعي من البنوك
الاصغر تم تخفيف القيود على البنوك الاصغر
في الولايات المتحده من ناحيه السيوله من
ناحيه ستريس وغيره بالتالي لا تطبق عليها
نفس القيود المفروضه على البنوك الاكبر من
ضمن هذه البنوك سيليكون فالي بنك والبنوك
الاخرى المتعثره لليوم شفنا بنوك مماثله
عم بتسجل تراجعات
كبيره جدا وتم وقف التداول عليها في مطلع
التداولات مثل
تراجع باكثر من 65% مثلها
ولكن البنوك الاكبر وضع افضل كما تلاحظون
في امريكا كود من تراجعات فيها
محدوده بالمقارنه مع الخسائر اللي شفناها
بالبنوك الاكبر هذا الوضع مشاهدينا اليوم
ايضا عم نشوف اتجاهات نحو الملاذات الامنه
لذلك عم نشوف ارتفاعات كبيره باسعار
السندات تراجع كبير بعوائد السندات
الخزانه الامريكيه حول العالم حتى ولكن
الخسائر كانت اكبر من ذلك قلسنا جزء من
هذه الخسائر ولكن لاحظوا عائد السنتين يلي
تراجع دون مستويات الاربعه بالمئه خلال
تداولات اليوم يعود الى فوق مستويات
الاربعه في المئه على كل مشاهدينا ايضا
يجب الاشاره بانه الاسواق الاوروبيه اغلقت
واغلقت على المشروعات كذلك اليوم عم نتحدث
عن خسائر للاسواق الاوروبيه بضغط اساسي من
القطاع المصرفي يلي سجل هذا القطاع اسوا
يومين من التراجع يعني خلال جلستين خلال
فتره عام لم نراها
عند مستويات متدنيه تاريخيه البورصه
البريطانيه عند ادنى مستوياتها في عامين
وها هي اطلاقات اذا البنوك الاوروبيه كان
فيها تراجعات قويه
على الوحده البريطانيه اليوم اغلق على
تراجع باربعه على كل للمزيد حول تطورات
الاسواق الامريكيه ينضم الينا مباشره من
القاهره احمد نجم رئيس قسم الابحاث في اكس
اس دوت كوم احمد اهلا وسهلا بك كل الانظار
متجهه الى اجتماع الفيدرالي الاستثنائي
الذي بدا اليوم مع عنا معلومات بعد حول
هذا الاجتماع ما هي توقعاتك لنتائج
الاجتماع
طبعا
اغلبكم على الاستضافه الامر يمكن الاجتماع
ده هيكون يعني يصيروا كثير جدا من الجده
خصوصا هل يكون بالفعل هنالك تراجع
الفيدرالي الامريكي عن لهجه التشدد في
الفتره المقبله خصوصا بعد ما سعرته
الاسواق تماما اصبحت الخمسين نقطه مختفيه
تماما من التوقعات الان اصبحت التوقعات
اما برفع 25 نقطه او التثبيت على اي من
الجانبين ربما سيكون الفيدرالي متخذ لقرار
نتيجه ايضا للبيانات التضخم التي يعني
ربما نشرها خلال الغد ولكن هو السيناريو
المطروحه الان هو ماذا بعد اذا قام
الفيدرالي بالتمهل يعني وتيره التجديد او
على قله تثبيت على الاقامه الحالمه زال
معدل التضخم مرتفع كثيرا عن مستدافات
الفيدران الامريكي وبالتالي هي اشاره كيف
سيكون هنالك انخفاض بوتيره اكبر لهزيه
مسابقه الاثنين في المئه او حتى اذا
تحدثنا عن في الماء فهو ايضا ما زال بعيد
كيف سيكون الوصول الى هذا المستوى مع هذا
الامر
لم يعطي الاسواق اي اشاره حول انه ربما
سيكون هنالك تمهل في الفتره المقبله ولكن
الاسواق من تلقاء نفسها توقعت هذا الامر
الى الاسواق يعني دائما يعني مع كل ارقام
او مع كل ازمه كل المشاده في الفتره
الماضيه منذ بدايه التسعير لان تكون يعني
هنالك انهاء لهذا البرنامج كانت الاسواق
دائما ما تبحث عن سيناريو ايجابي او فرصه
ايجابيه في الفتره المقبله لانهاء هذا
البرنامج وتسعير هذا الامر في السلطه يمكن
يعني مشاهدناه في التداولات خلال اليوم من
الارتفاعات مره اخرى هو تسعير هذا الامر
بشكل كامل
في ظل العوده للارتفاع في الاسواق ماذا
تقول لنا هل برايك نجحت السلطات الامريكيه
في تهدئه المخاوف حول وجود ازمه في القطاع
المصرفي
السلطات الامريكيه نجحت بشكل كبير جدا في
النهايه تطمن
المدعين في البنوك على ان اموالكم
كبير جدا حول فكره الودائع المؤمنه وغير
المؤمنه نسبه المؤمنه في البنوك بالنتيجه
مقارنه مع غير المؤمنه وكانت يعني الارقام
التي شاهدتها من الابحات حول ان اكثر من
97% تقريبا وغير مؤمن عليها وبالتالي هي
الكارثه كانت ستلعب بهذه العين قام باقامه
السلطات الامريكيه التطمين المدعين ولكن
ادت لازمه كبيره جدا وهي ان لن يكون هنالك
تعويض لحركه الاسهم لن يكون هنالك تعويض
للمستثمرين سيتركون يتجدون خسائرهم
وبالتالي يمكن الضغط الكبير والضغوطه
الكبيره اليوم على اسهم البنوك هي نتيجه
لهذا الامر الجميع التخوف وبالتالي يتخرج
بشكل او باخر وحتى مع يعني اعلان عن الحزن
التي هو القرض الذي سيتم دعمه للبنوك لمده
عام هو يعني يعطي نوع من التقنين
للمستثمرين في هذه البنوك ستكون البنوك
الكبرى هي المستفيده الاكبر من هذه الازمه
ستعاني البنوكاسوره لكن ايضا سيعاني شركات
الناشئه لان فكره الحصول على تمويل ودعم
من البنوك ستكون تحتاج الى مزيد من الوقت
ومعقده في الفتره المقبله وبالتالي تتاثر
عملها زي الشركه شكرا لك احمد نجم رئيس
قسم الابحاث في اكس اس دوت كوم
يجب الاشاره هنا مشاهدينا الى موضوع ان
هناك دعوه جماعيه من قبل المساهمين لانه
المساهمين بمصرف اس بي بي غير محميين بهذه
الخطه الانقاذ التي وضعت هي فقط تحمي
المذيعين يبدو بانه هناك دعوه جماعيه من
المساهمين ضد المصرف وضد الرئيس المالي
والرئيس التنفيذي للمصرف لانهم اخفوا
كيفيه التاثر البنك بالارتفاعات السريعه
لاسعار الفائده على كل دعونا نعود الان
الى زميله ليال لاستكمال نشره الاخبار
شكرا لنا
[موسيقى]
ولاد مشاهدينا ننتقل الى اخر تطورات الحرب
في اوكرانيا سياسيا وميدانيا
تحدثت صحيفه
نقلا عن مصادر مقربه من الرئيس الصيني
عن انه سيجتمع بالرئيس الاوكراني
عبر تقنيه الفيديو لاول مره منذ الحرب في
اوكرانيا واشارت الصحيفه الى ان اللقاء
سيكون عقب زياره
كما قالت انه من المرجح ان يكون لرئيس
الصيني زيارات لدول اوروبيه اخرى بعد
زياره موسكو
بدوره انتقد المتحدث باسم الاتحاد
الاوروبي للشؤون الخارجيه والسياسيه
والامنيه الصين بشان مقترحاتها التي
قدمتها لحل الصراع في اوكرانيا واعتبر في
مؤتمر صحفي عقده فيبروكسال ردا على سؤال
عن من احد الصحفيين على انبكين اظهرت من
خلال موقفها انها تنحاز الى جانب واحد في
هذا الصراع لانها ترفض تحديد من هو
المعتدي ومن هو الضحيه على حد وصفه
بينما في موسكو يصر لك رمل على ان لا حل
في اوكرانيا الا عسكريا المتحدث باسم كريم
لاندي قال ان اهداف روسيا في اوكرانيا لا
يمكن ان تتحقق الان الا بالوسائل العسكريه
واضف بسكوب انه بالنسبه لروسيا ما تزال
الاولويه المطلقه وستظل دائما هي تحقيق
كامل اهداف العمليه العسكريه التي تشنها
موسكو ضد اوكرانيا منذ اكثر من عام لكن
وبالتزامن مع هذه التهديدات اشار المتحدث
باسم كريم الى انه لا توجد شروط مسبقه
للانتقال الى مسار السلام
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا عبر سكايب من موسكو
رائد جبر مدير مكتب صحيفه الشرق الاوسط في
موسكو رائد يعني سياسه الامريكيه التي
كانت قائمه بالفتره الاخيره على عزل الصين
تسعى الصين اليوم لكسره عبر مبادرات
السلام التي تقوم بها ان كان بالشرق
الاوسط وان كان على الجبهه الاوكرانيه
الروسيه اليوم يعني الموقف الروسي هل هو
موقف مكابره فقط ام انه فعلا تعنت من قبل
الكريم لعدم الذهاب الى مفاوضات قبل تحقيق
مكاسب حقيقيه
نعم مساء الخير يعني انا لا اعتقد ان
الموضوع يكمن في التعنت فقط طبعا الموقف
الروسي موقف يعني وضعت موسكو خطوط حمراء
واضحه وهي ما زالت متمسكه بها لكن ابعد من
فكره التعنت انه المبادئ او
الافكار الان لم تكن يعني افكار عمليه
يمكن تنفيذها اجرائيه على الارض وهي ليس
فقط لا ترضي الجانب الغربي وهذا هو سبب
يعني هذا الاتصالات النشطه التي يجريها
الزعيم الصيني وسوف يجريها مع اطراف عديده
في الغرب لانه مقتنع انه الغرب ليس راضيا
عن هذه الافكار لكن ايضا هي بالمناسبه
ليست مرضيه بشكل كامل لموسكو لان موسكو
تنطلق من انه الافكار العامه التي طرحتها
الصين تمثلت حول فكره احترام او بالمقدمه
منها كان احترام سيادته وحده الاراضي وهو
امر موسكو تشكك به بالنسبه الى اوكرانيا
بشكل واضح ورسمي وعلني اصلا
اعتقد انه المباحثات التي سيجريها الزعيم
الصيني في موسكو ستكون لها اهميه خاصه
لمحاوله تقريب وجهات النظر وربما الخروج
ببعض الافكار التي يمكن ان توصف بانها
عمليه لطرحها على الاط راف الاخرى بالدرجه
الاولى على الطرف الاوكرينه
بالدرجه لاحقه ربما على الاطراف الاوروبيه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه من المعلوم
ان هناك خوف صيني بشان يعني نتائج هذا
الصراع على الساحه الاوروبيه مما ينعكس
على الاقتصاد الصيني وعلى الدوري الصيني
هناك اليوم يعني الفائده الاساسيه للصين
من عوده السلام بين اوكرانيا وروسيا
يعني الصين من الدول التي استفادت يعني
بين قوسين صح
التعبير على ما يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال
بالزميل رائد جابر مدير مكتب صحيفه الشرق
الاوسط عوده اليك رائد
نعم نعم كنت اقول انه الصين استفادت جزئيا
من هذه من هذه الحرب لانها حصلت على
الطاقم الاسعار منخفضه ولكن التوتر
المتزايد في العالم كله واليات تغيير
النظام الدولي التي نشهدها الان طبعا على
المدى البعيد امر مقلق بالنسبه الى الصين
وتحاول الصين ان تلعب ادوار سياسيه كما
ذكرت في المقدم قبل قليل تحاول ان تلعب
ادوار سياسيه مهمه لتهدئه التوتر في اكثر
من منطقه لذلك
تحاول تصير فعله الان اذا نجحت بالفعل في
التوصل الى تهدئه للحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه على الاقل وقف اطلاق نار غير
مشروط وربما فتح قنوات حوار هذا سيكون
انجاز مهم جدا للدبلوماسيه الصينيه وربما
يؤسس لمرحله جديده ان الصين باتت قادره
على ان تشكل وساطه في ملفات اقليميه وفي
ملفات عائدات اهميه عالميه كما يحصل الان
في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه شكرا لك راء
جابر مدير مكتب صحيفه الشرق الاوسط في
موسكو
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
لاول مره
يتم التوصل الى اتفاق بعد سنوات من الخلاف
رئيس الوزراء العراقي يعلن التوصل لاتفاق
حول ارادات النفط مع
[موسيقى]
اصرار انكرانية لشهور على تحصيل مجموعه من
الاسلحه تقدمتها دبابات
تمسك اوكرانيا بالدبابه او تمسك اوكرانيا
بالدبابه الالمانيه صنع اسبابهم متعدده
دبابه قتال رئيسيه دخلت الخدمه قبل نحو
سته عقود لكنها خضعت لعمليات تطوير عده
لتصبح واحده من افضل دبابات العالم من
ناحيه دقه الاصابه
والحمايه وخفت الحركه السلاح الرئيسي في
الدبابه هو مدفع عيار 120 مليمتر يتماشى
مع معايير حلف الناتو اضافه لرشاشين
وقاذفه قنابل تتميز بمحرك ديزل مزدوج
يمكنها قطع مسافه 340 كيلو مترا بسرعات
تصل الى اثنين وسبعين كيلو مترا في الساعه
على خزان وقود واحد ويبلغ وزنها مشاهدينا
اثنين وستين ط وطولها عشره امتار وتضم
طاقما مكونا من اربعه افراد يتمتعون بنظام
رؤيه ليليه ونهاريه لمسافات بعيده اثبتت
التجربه الموثوقه في ساحه المعركه بسبب
قله اعطالها وقدره تحملها العاليه مقارنه
بالدبابات الاخرى كما انها الخيار المثالي
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا كونها الاكثر انتشارا
بين الدول الاوروبيه الاعضاء في دول
الناتو وفي حلف الناتو بعدد يفوق الالف
2300 دبابه ويمكن نقلها برا بسهوله طبعا
الى اوكرانيا وتامين الذخيره التي تتطلبها
هذه الدبابه
[موسيقى]
الخلافات بين قوات فاجنر الروسيه وموسكوت
تتفاقم معهد الدراسات الحرب الامريكيه
خلوصه الى ان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تعطي
الاولويه حاليا للقضاء على قوات فاكتور
في ذروه المعارك المحتدمه في ضخمه
الاوكرانيه خطر اساسي يهدد التقدم الروسي
وهو خلافات الصف الواحد بين مجموعه فكنر
التي تقاتل في المدينه والكرملين
ذهب اليه معهد دراسات الحرب الامريكي الذي
يرى ان الدفاع الروسيه تعطي الاولويه
حاليا للقضاء على قوات فاجنر في ضخمه بعد
الهجوم الحاد من قبل بريكوجين على وزير
الدفاع السيرجيو ورئيس الاركان العامه
هناك مواجهه مباشره لا تقل عن كونها
محاوله لتدمير فاغنر وترقى الى خيانه
للوطن في حين تقاتل فاجنر من اجل باخموت
وتتكبد خسائر بشريه بالمئات كل يوم
الشقاق واحد وصل لدرجه قطع وزاره الدفاع
الذخيره عن فاغنر بعد ان استنفذت كامله
ذخيلتها في المعارك وطلبت موسكو
بالامدادات الغريب ان الدفاع الروسيه قطعت
طرق التواصل مع فاجنر رغم ان الاخيره
تحققت تقدما لافتا شرقيه اوكرانيا وضمنت
لموسكو السيطره على المزيد من الاراضي
بعض المحللين يرون ان موسكو تتارجح بين
رغبتين الاولى هي انتزاع بخموت كنصر
استراتيجي يمهد الطريق نحو غربي اوكرانيا
والثانيه هي التغلب على مخاوف بوتين من
طموحات التوسعيه ومؤخرا كانت تقارير غربيه
تنبات
الى منظومه عسكريه موازيه تحمل طابعا
ايديولوجيا ويكون لها دورها المنفصل عن
الكرملين في اوكرانيا
عمر العربيه
اعلنت الخارجيه الروسيه على انتهاء
المحادثات مع الامم المتحده بشان تمديد
اتفاق الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود واكدت
الخارجيه الروسيه ان موسكو خاضت بتفاصيل
تمديد اتفاق الحبوب مع الامم المتحده وان
روسيا لا تعارض تمديد الاتفاق ولكن لمده
60 يوما فقط
بدورها اعربه الخارجيه البريطانيه او
بريطانيا عن استعدادها للعوده الى حوار
كامل مع روسيا لحل المشاكل العالميه بعد
تسويه الصراع في اوكرانيا حيث اشار ممثل
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسوناك بلادها
على العمل مع روسيا عندما تاتي اللحظه
المناسبه لاداره مخاطر الانظمه الجيوسيه
وبان بلادهم مستعده للتعاون مع اي دوله
بشرط احترام استقرار النظام العالمي وافاد
بان قنوات الحوار وخفض التصعيد مع روسيا
محدوده بشكل كبير لكن يمكن احيائها عندما
يحين الوقت
هذا وافادت مصادر لرويتورز ان المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه تنوي اصدار مذكرات
اعتقال في قضيه اختطاف روسيا للاطفال في
اوكرانيا واستهداف البنيه التحتيه وقالت
رويترز ان هذه المذكرات ستستهدف عددا من
الافراد الروس كما انها ستكون الاولى التي
ستتحقق في الحرب في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
صفقه الغواصات النوويه التي تنوي استراليا
الحصول عليها دخلت مرحله هندسه اللمسات
الاخيره هذه الصفقه تقدر بحوالي 37 مليار
دولار
وستشتري بموجبها استراليا نحو اربع غواصات
امريكيه تعمل بالطاقه النوويه من طراز
فيرجينيا او وسط فرجينيا التي يستبعد
تسليمها قبل ثلاثينيات القرن الحالي هي
احدث غواصه هجوميه سريعه في البحريه
الامريكيه تملك القدره على استخدام اسلحه
مختلفه بما فيها التوربيدات وصواريخ كروز
وتنفذ مهام استخباراتيه واستطلاعيه صفقات
الغواصات تاتي بموجب تحالف اوكس الثلاثي
الذي اعلن عنه عام 2021 بين كل من
استراليا والولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
ويهدف طبعا الى المواجهه ومواجهه الوجود
العسكري المتنامي للصين وتحديدا في منطقه
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وشكلت هذه الصفقه
موضوع خلاف حاد حيدها بين استراليا وفرنسا
فالاخيره كما نذكر اقصيت من هذا المشروع
بعد ضغوط امريكيه واستراليا طبعا عوضت
شركه نافال الفرنسيه بخمس مئه وخمسه
وخمسين مليون دولار
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الصيني شيت جينج اكد على ان بلاده
ستعمل على تعزيز امنها القومي للحفاظ على
استقرارها مشددا انا ستمضي قدما في حملتها
للتعبئه وستؤسس جيشا قويا ليحمي امنها
ومصالحها فلنتابعها
الامن هو اساس التنميه والاستقرار هو
الشرط الاساسي للازدهار وعلينا تنفيذ نهج
شامل للامن القومي وتحسين نظام الامن
القومي لدينا وتعزيز قدرتنا على حمايه
الامن القومي وتعزيز اداره السلامه العامه
وكذلك تحسين نظام الحوكمه الاجتماعيه
لضمان نموذج انمائي جديد
يجب علينا المضي قدما في حملتنا للتعبئه
فيما يتعلق بالدفاع الوطني والجيش
وتحويل جيش الصين الى جدار كبير من الصلب
وبالحديث مشاهدينا عن العلاقات الغربيه مع
الصين قالت مجله بوليتيكول الامريكيه ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي يواجه القساما واضحا
وذلك بشان استراتيجيه التعامل مع الصين
واضافت المجله ان الرئيس رئيس المجلس
الاوروبي لا يريد ازمه مع الصين ورئيسه
المفوضيه تتبنى سياسه الولايات المتحده
هذا وقال مسؤول اوروبي لمجلات بوليتيكو ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي ليس تابعا لامريكا وانه
وانه لا يجب الانفصال عن الصين على الرغم
من خشيه الثائر من الصراع الامريكيه
الصيني
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا منه واشنطير غانم
مراسل العربيه يعني استراليا التي لطالما
استبعدت ان تكون قوه نوويه اليوم يعني هو
يمثل تحول في مسار استراليا ما اهميه وجود
هذه الغواصات بهذه النقطه من العالم
بالذات
يريد الامريكيون من استراليا ان تذهب ابعد
من حدودها حدود ارضها وبحرها وان تكون هي
الحليف الاساسي في مواجهه التحركات
العسكريه
الصينيه وبالتالي هذا المشروع الذي يبدا
الان باعطاء استراليا ثلاث غواصات تسير
بالقوه النوويه وتستطيع ان تحمل ايضا
صواريخ نوويه هدفه على المدى القريب هو
بدايه الرداء على المدى البعيد هو ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واستراليا
وايضا بريطانيا ينتظرون ان تكون الصين
اكثر حده في علاقاتها العسكريه مع جيرانها
وعلى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تستعد
الى المرحله على المدى الطويل
يعني هذا المشروع سيحتاج الى سنوات لكي
يتم تحقيقه ما هو المسار يعني العملي لهذا
المشروع
نبدا اولا بالمشروع سوف تعطي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ثلاث غواصات لاستراليا
وعمليه التسليم سوف تتم قبل العام 2027
الجزء الثاني من المشروع ستكون بريطانيا
في هذا المشروع الغواصات اسمح لي ان اشير
الى هذا العاجل الذي ورد الان بخصوص هذا
الموضوع بان استراليا ستشتري من واشنطن
خمس غواصات نوويه بحسب مسؤول امريكا
المرحله الثانيه هي بناء الغواصات
بمساعده بريطانيه وتبدا عمليات البناء
بشكل خاص في استراليا ثم تصبح استراليا
ربما في اواسط الثلاثينيات اي بعدها اقله
عشر سنوات او اكثر من ذلك تستطيع ان
تستعمل التكنولوجيا الامريكيه لبناء
الغواصات على اراضيها هذا يعني ان هناك
مشروع بعيد الامد وهناك ليس شكوك ولكن
هناك انتظار طويل لانه ليست استراليا
معروفه بهذه الصناعه وتحتاج الى وقت طويل
جدا لتتمكن من عمليه التصنيع ايضا ابناء
باطار هذا الحلف يعني ايضا البريطانيين
اعلنوا عن رفض مزيد من الاموال لتعزيز
الحمايه بهذه المنطقه تخوفا من الصين هل
نتوقع يعني مشاريع اخرى بالمرحله المقبله
هناك وعي لدى الاوروبيين وايضا الامريكيين
ان الصين تشكل تحدي حقيقي وبالتالي يجب ان
يبدا العالم ببناء قوه تواجه هذا التمدد
الصيني ربما نرى اكثر على صعيد الصناعات
البحريه وايضا صناعات الطيران وسوف تكون
استراليا عمليه هي راس الحربه في هذه
المنطقه شكرا
المراسل العربيه حدثنا منه واشنطن
[موسيقى]
في العراق وبعد سنوات من الخلاف اعلن رئيس
الوزراء محمد شاع السوداني عن التوصل الى
اتفاق ينهي الخلاف بين بغداد واربيل حول
ايرادات نفط اقليم كردستان وقال السوداني
ان الاتفاق بشان النفط والغاز تم من خلال
وضع ايرادات نفط الاقليم في حساب المصرفي
واحد ويقول الحساب رئيس مجلس وزراء
الاقليم ورئيس مجلس الوزراء الاتحادي
بمراقبه الحساب وستكون هناك لجنه ترفع
توصياتها الى رئيس وزراء الاتحاديه لاتخاذ
القرار المناسب ويعد ملف تصدير ايرادات
النفط في اقليم كردستان احد ابرز نقاط
الخلاف بين بغداد واربيل لا سيما مع الغاء
المحكمه الاتحاديه العليا بالعراق دستوريه
قانون النفط والغاز في اقليمي كردستان
ولله الحمد خرجنا باتفاق
شامل
حول القضايا التي
تمثل مشاكل عالقه بين بغداد واربيل لاول
مره
يتم التوصل الى اتفاق
بان
يتم ايداع الايرادات الكليه
للنفط المنتج من حقول الاقليم في حساب
مصرفي واحد تودع فيه جميع الايرادات
المتاتيه من تصدير او بيع النفط الخام
ومشتقاته بدون اي استقطاعات لاي غرض كان
ويخول رئيس مجلس وزراء الاقليم او من
يخونه بصلاحيه الصرف ويخضع الحساب المذكور
لرقابه الحكومه الاتحاديه وتغلق كافه
الحسابات المماثله الاخرى
وفيها بعد
لتسريع عمليه اعاده التطبيع بين انقره
ونظام الاسد موسكو تستضيف اجتماعا رباعيا
حول سوريا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في المغرب انتقدت ديوان
الملكي المغربي حزب العداله والتنميه
الاسلاميه لتداخله في السياسات الخارجيه
ووصف بيان صدر عن الديوان الملكي عن الحزب
عن تدخل الحزب بشان العلاقات مع اسرائيل
بانه غير موضوعي وبه مغالطات كثيره واضاف
بيان ديوان الملكي المغربي ان حزب العداله
والتنميه تدخل في اختصاصات تعود للملك
وشدد على ان استغلال الاجنده الخارجيه
للبلاد في اغراض حزبيه سابقه خطيره
اعتبر الديوان الملكي في المغرب ان حزب
العداله والتنميه اصدر بيانا تضمن تجاوزات
غير مسؤوله
ومغالطات خطيره عن علاقات المغرب مع
اسرائيل وربطها بالتطورات في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله انعلم جميعا وقع
القضيه الفلسطينيه على وجدان المغاربه وهي
تاتي في نفس المرتبات قضيه الوحده
الترابيه وبالتالي فان قوه ديون السياسيه
من خلال عشر سنوات عجاف تحاول اللعب على
عواطف المغاربه من خلال مزايده بقضيه
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي لا يمكن استغلال
التحولات الاقليميه للمشاهده بهدف عوده
انتخابيين او سياسويا الديوان الملكي في
المغرب اوضح ان القضيه الفلسطينيه من
اولويات السياسه الخارجيه للعاهل المغربي
الملك محمد السادس بالاغديو الملكي تجهز
العداله والتنميه حيال التطورات ديال
القضيه الفلسطينيه يعبر عن انزعاج واضح من
خلال البلاغ ولغته من المواقف التي يعبر
عليها حزب العداله والتنميه عشر سنوات من
التدبير في الحكومه للعداله والتنميه
ومشاركه اكثر من 14 وزير وكون رئيس حكومه
سابق سعد الدين العثماني وزير خارجيه في
لحظه من اللحظات تقتضي ان يفهم ان المخطط
والذي يراس
للخارجيه هو ملك البلاد في رساله مباشره
الى اخوان المغرب اعتبر الديوان الملكي
المغربي ان مواقف الرباط لا تخدع
للمزايدات السياسيه او للحملات الانتخابيه
الضيقه فيما العداله والتنميه طالب قيادته
وقواعده بعدم التعليق باي شكل من الاشكال
تكراره هجوم حزب العداله والتنميه المعارض
على الدبلوماسيه المغربيه على خلفيه
القضيه الفلسطينيه دفع بحسب مراقبين
السلطات المغربيه الى اصدار بيان شديد
الله جه يوضح مواقف الرباط من القضيه
الفلسطينيه ويوضح طبيعه استئناف العلاقات
المغربيه الاسرائيليه عادل الزبير العربيه
الرباط
اكد قائد الجيش الليبي خليفه حفتر ومبعوث
الامم المتحده الى ليبيا عبد الله باتيلي
على اهميه دعم جهود البرلمان والمجلس
الاعلى للدوله لاستكمال القاعده الدستوريه
واجراء الانتخابات من خلال العمل وفق
الخطه الامميه في المرحله القادمه وكان
بيتي لقد طرح مؤخرا امام مجلس الامن
الدولي مبادره لاجراء الانتخابات
البرلمانيه والرئاسيه الليبيه التي تعذر
اجراؤها في ديسمبر من العام 2021
قالت تلفزيون تون مجلس النواب الجديد
انتخب ابراهيم بودرباله عميد المحامين
السابق رئيسا له عقب جوله تصويت ثانيه
بعدما فشل المرشحون لرئاسه البرلمان في
الحصول على اغلبيه خلال الجلسه الافتتاحيه
في وقت سابق الاثنين لتقام جوله تصويت
ثانيه حسمها بودرباله لصالحه بعد التفوق
على منافسه عبد السلام الدحماني هذا وكاله
الجلسه الافتتاحيه للمجلس النيابي المنتخب
حديثا في تونس انعقد بعد انقطاع عندما
اكثر من سنه ونصف اثرى تجميد اعمال المجلس
التشريعيه السابق بقرار من رئيس الجمهوريه
[موسيقى]
اجتماع رباعي تركي سوري ايراني وروسي يعقد
يومي الاربعاء والخميس المقبلين في
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو التي سيحضر عنها
الممثل الخاص للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين في الشرق الاوسط ودول الافريقيه
ميخائيل بغدانوف وعن الجانب الايراني
سيحضر مستشار الشؤون السياسيه علي اصغر
حاجه ونائب وزير الخارجيه السوريه ايمن
سوسان ممثلا النظام السوري بينما سيارئس
الوفد التركي نائب وزير الخارجيه التركي
بوراك اكاجبار سيراس الوفد التركي خلال
الاجتماع هذا ما اعلنته طبعا وكاله
الاناضول التركيه
[موسيقى]
اما عن الجانب السوري تحديدا المشاهدين
نقلت صحيفه الوطن المقربه من النظام ان
المعطيات اللازمه لانعقاد الاجتماعي
الرباعي بين نواب وزراء خارجيه تركيا
وسوريا وروسيا وايران لم تنضج بعد وذكرت
الصحيفه ان موقف نظام الاسد ما زال على
حاله حتى الحصول على ضمانات تركيا تحديدا
بالانسحاب من اراضيها قبل اي لقاء سياسي
يجمع الطرفين على طاوله مباحثات واحده هذا
كان عن موقف النظام لكن ماذا عن المعارضه
السوريه والتي تتخذ من تركيا مقرا رئيسا
لها هذه المعارضه ورغم تطمينات انقره
باستمرار بدعمها الا انها تبدو وكانها
منقسمه على نفسها بسبب الخلافات التي تعصف
بها داخليا والتي جعلت كل طرف من هذه
المعارضه يميل الى الموقف التركي والاخر
ضد لكن بدون القدره طبعا على التاثير
جزء اكبر من المعارضه السوريه ما يزال
يراهن على وعود تركيا بعدم التخلي عنها
وان اهدافها من التقارب ستكون تلبيه
لمصالح ولمصلحه المعارضه مؤكدين ايضا بان
انقره كانت ولا تزال الضامن والوسيط
النزيه لحل الازمه بحسب الحقوق المعارض
ياسر الفرحان طبعا هنا يعتبر اخرون ان
التقارب التركي الروسي خنجر في خاصره
المعارضه التي ستكون الخاسر الاكبر وسوف
تفقد اهم اوراقها وهو ما يعني تريده دائما
ان تنتزعه من الاسد جميع الاوراق من
المعارضه طبعا سينتزعها بهذه الحاله الاسد
والنظامه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من اسطنبول للدكتور
سمير صالحه الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه
دكتور سمير سابدا من موضوع انقسام
المعارضه يعني هو بالاساس المعارضه كان
لديها مشاكل داخليه كثيره في الاونه
الاخيره واليوم التقارب التركي السوري
يربك اكثر المعارضه التي تتخذ من تركيا
مقر اساسي لها كيف يعني يمكن ان تتعاطى مع
هذا التقارب
نعم مساء الخير اولا يعني اتفق معك من حق
المعارضه السوريه خصوصا الائتلاف الوطني
الذي ينسق مع تركيا منذ سنوات ان يقلق
لهذه القمه لماذا لانه لا نعرف اهداف هذا
الاجتماع الرباعي حتى الان يعني كل طرف
يتحدث عن رؤيته لكن يبدو انه لا يوجد جدول
اعمال مشترك حتى الساعه كما فهمنا انقر
لها اولوياتها متمسكه بها دمشق ايضا
وروسيا وايران يحاولان الان يدخلها على
الخط باتجاه ايجاد هذه الصيغه لذلك نعم
وجود المعارضه
السوريه خارج المشهد مساله فعلا تحتاج الى
نقاش حقيقي مولود شاوش اوغلو كما تتذكرين
قبل ايام تحدث عن توسيع هذه
الطاوله هل كان المقصود هنا ان يفتح
الطريق امام مشاركه قوى المعارضه السوريه
كطرف جديد خامس في هذه الطاوله لا نعرف
ايضا هل يعني هذا هو المقصود ام انه يتحدث
عن لاعبين اقليمين اخرين يعني في جميع
الاحوال في الكثير من علامات الاستفهام
حول اهداف الطاوله جدول اعمالها وما الذي
ستناقشه ايضا على الطاوله الاطراف
الرئيسيه الموجوده هنا اتحدث عن الايراني
وعن التركي وعن السوري لهم شروط مسبقه قبل
الجلوس الى هذه الطاوله سابدا بالسوري
السوري يعني الشروط اكبر بكثير وهو ليس
بموقع التنازل لصالح تركيا كما موقع اليوم
اردوغان المضغوط عليه بسبب الانتخابات كيف
يمكن يعني ان
يتبلور هذا الموضوع
يعني بالنسبه لانقره النظام ليس في موقع
القوه ليقدم شروط ويفرض ما يريد على
الطاوله بالنسبه لانقره هي تنسق كما
تعرفين منذ سنوات مع الجانبين الروسي
والايراني سواء كان تحت سقف منصه
الاسيتانا او في تفاهمات التركيه الروسيه
انا اظن انه النظام يحاول الان ان يعني
يقوي من الناحيه السياسيه والنفسيه
ذهابي الى الطاوله عبر الحديث عن شروط
مسبقه لكن في نهايه الامر الحوار التركي
الروسي تحديدا هو الذي سيحسم المساله وشكل
هذه الطاوله او لبيئه النظام موجوده نعم
ربما لكن انكر ايضا لها الكثير من
الاولويات التي ستطرحها على المجتمعين
ولكن يعني بموازاه ذلك اليوم الرئيس
التركي بحاجه لهذه الصوره ولهذه المصالحه
على ابواب الانتخابات بظل الضغوط بوجه
المعارضه داخليا وبالتالي يعني من مصلحته
التنازل بمكان ما ما الذي يمكن ان يتنازل
به خصوصا وقت شروط سوريا بموضوع قصد
بموضوع الانسحاب من الاراضي وغيرها
يعني طبعا تركيا ذاهبه الى انتخابات نعم
مبكره بعد شهرين لكن موضوع ربطها بموضوع
الملف السوري في بشقه السياسي والازمه ككل
لا اظن انه خلال هذه الفتره الزمنيه سيكون
هناك اختراق حقيقي في التعامل مع الموضوع
ربما الاختراق الوحيد الذي قد نراه هو في
موضوع اللاجئين وربما تفاهمات في موضوع
شمال سوريا المنطقه الامنه
والمرتبطه بشقها
لن يعطي الملف دون تنازلات باماكن اخرى
لانه يعلم الحاجه التركيه في
نعم النظام ربما الان كما قلت لك سيحمل
معه الكثير من المطالب والشروط المهم هو
هل من الممكن بالنسبه لانقره ان تكون
منفتحه على هذه المطالب وشروط لا اظن انكر
عندها اولويات كثيره يعرفها النظام مثلا
هذه الضمانات الامنيه الواسعه التي تريدها
في شمال سوريا حسب موضوع ورقه قصد بشكل او
باخر
والاهم من كل ذلك التعاون في موضوع تسهيل
عوده مئات الالاف من اللاجئين هل النظام
قادر على دعم هذه الشروط والوقوف الى
جانبها وتنفيذها هذه الطاوله لنرى مخرجات
شكرا لك دكتور سمير صالحه الاستاذ في
العلاقات الدوليه حدثنا من اسطنبول
افاد رئيس لجنه تحقيق عينتها الامم
المتحده لتحقيق بشان سوريا بان كلا من
المنظمه الدوليه والنظام السوري وبعض
الجهات تتحمل مسؤوليات التاخير في ايصال
المساعدات الى السوريين بعد الزلزال
فلنستمع
منذ وقوع الزلزال شهدنا العديد من الاعمال
البطوليه لمساعده الضحايا من قبل السوريين
انفسهم لكننا شهدنا ايضا فشلا تاما من قبل
حكومه النظام والمجتمع الدولي بما في ذلك
الامم المتحده في توجيه مساعدات عاجله
لانقاذ الارواح في شمال غرب سوريا ضاعت
ايام عديده دون اي مساعده للناجين من
الزلزال سيريا
[موسيقى]
تكدست اكوام القمامه في احياء وشوارع
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس مع استمرار حركه
الاضرابات والاحتجاجات المناهضه لمشروع
قانون رفع سن التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64
عاما فيما تخطط النقابات لتنظيم المزيد من
المسيرات والاحتجاجات او المسيرات
والاحتجاجات
[موسيقى]
اعلنت هيئه الاذاعه البريطانيه اعاده واحد
من اشهر مذيعيها واعلاهم اجرا
لاداء مهامه ما يضع حدا لخلاف حاد بين
المذيع والمحطه بعد انتقاده لسياسه
الحكومه البريطانيه بشان الهجره وكانت
البي بي سي اوقفت المذيع بداعي مخالفه
لوائح الحياديه بعدما قارن خطاب وزيره
الداخليه البريطانيه باللغه المستخدمه في
المانيا النازيه
اهتزت مصداقيه بي بي سي احدى اكثر
المؤسسات وثوقا في بريطانيا بعد ان وجدت
نفسها وسط سجال اعلامي اثارته تغريده
لاشهر مذيعها فبعد نهايه اسبوع حافله
بانسحابات جماعيه من صحفيين ومذيعين من
برامج القناه اضطرت بي بي سي لدعوه جاري
لينكر الى العوده الى العمل بعد تقديمها
اعتذارا رسميا له
من جانبه قبل الاعتذار ووافق على العوده
لكن تداعيات الجدل لم تنتهي بعد رغم
اعتذارها الا ان القناه تقول انه سيلتزم
بتعاليم القناه التحريريه ولكن ما هي هذه
التعاليم الحياه كما تقول القناه لكنها
ليست المره الاولى التي يعبر فيها صحفيون
في البي بي سي عن ارائهم السياسيه التي
يقولون انها ابسط حقوقهم المدنيه وعلى
راسها حريه التعبير المضمونه في بريطانيا
جدل بشان القواعد التي تريد بي بي سي
فرضها على موظفيها ومذيعها فيما يخص
استخدام وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بما في
ذلك جاري الذي يربطه عقد خاص بالبي بي سي
من الان وحتى مراجعه التعاليم سيلتزم جاري
بالارشادات التحريريه كان من الصعب الوصول
الى التوازن لكن مطالبه
في تلك اللحظه
لحريه التعبير قيمه كبيره بالنسبه
للبريطانيين في البلاد ولكن من جهه اخرى
يرى المدافعون عن الحكومه ان تشبيه
ليونيكور سياسه بلاده بالنازيه امر حساس
ويتجاوز المقبول به في حريه التعبير وبين
هذا وذاك يضيع التركيز على مضمون القضيه
الاساسيه وهي قوارب الهجره غير النظاميه
والتي اصر لنكر على اعاده التذكير بها رغم
الجدل الواسع الذي اثرته تغريدته السابقه
من لندن ع روب عبد الحق العربيه
[موسيقى]
هذا هو صرحت هيئه الاذاعه البريطانيه البي
بي سي عن عوده غاري لينك الى منصبه كمذيع
على الشاشه وذلك بعد الخلاف الحاصل بين
الطرفين اثر انتقاده طبعا سياسه الهجره
وعلى وسائل التواصل كما تابعنا في التقرير
الذي عرضناه قبل قليل
حصد فيلم
على اربع من جوائز الاوسكار في مهرجان
هوليود السينمائي فلنتابع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وختام التاسع مشاهدينا بعد اخبار الاوسكار
مع العلوين
يضع ثقل حكومته لمنع انهيار مزيد من
البنوك بعد سيليكون فالي واسهم البنوك
تربك البورصات
اول لقاء بين الرئيسين الاوكراني والصيني
سيكون عن بعد والكرملين يستبق القمه
اهدافنا لن تتحقق الا بالقوه
قمه الامريكيه بريطانيه استراليه عنوانها
بناء الغواصات النوويه لخلق توازن ببحر
الصين الجنوبي
بلغ دول الملكي تجهز العداله والتنميه
للتطورات ديال القضيه الفلسطينيه يعبر عن
انزعاج واضح من خلال البلاغ
من نوعها الديوان الملكي المغربي ينتقد
حزب العداله والتنميه
لمزاياداته على مواقف البلاد الخارجيه
الى هنا ناتي مشاهدينا الى ختام التاسعه
شكرا لحسن المتابعه والان انتقل الى 360
مع الزميله ميسون نويهد ميسون مساء الخير
بدايه وماذا لديك مساء الخير ليال طبعا
موضوع بنك سيليكون فالي هو ما زال متصدرا
سنتحدث ايضا عن اجتماع الرئيس بايدن مع
الرئيسين الاسرائيلي والبريطاني بخصوص
الغواصات النوويه وغيرها من الملفات فضلا
عن موضوع الاوسكار ونتائج اللي بيعتبرها
البعض كانت مفاجئه الى حد ما طبعا هناك
العديد ايضا من الاخبار نرجو ان تتابعينا